ah this is driving me insane to make a
lot of money you don't need to be a
genius you just need to remember a few
key things
ramit Sethi Financial expert the money
man New York Times bestseller has more
than 20 000 documented success stories
this is your chance to never worry about
money again you can live a rich life
regardless of where you came from
regardless of your income how many
people are clear on what their rich life
looks like less than one percent when I
talk to people who have a spending
problem 100 of the time they always say
the same thing I just need to earn more
if you double your income today do you
think your problems would disappear no
some of the stats I pulled out from your
book about 25 of people who made hundred
thousand dollars a year plus are still
living paycheck to paycheck makes us
realize that maybe the things we think
we need are things that we have been
socially taught are important for
example owning a house is the best
investment it means you are successful
but it can be a very bad financial
decision there are far better far
simpler Investments so I've got 100
pounds that I want to invest where do I
start I love that we're getting into the
nuts and bolts let's do this exercise
together and everyone can do it with us
first off and then got it now there's
just one more thing you have to do
do you know the math I would have 736
000 in my account yeah
ramits 10 Money Rules this is where the
real wealth is created number one
this episode changed my perspective on
money I'm an investor I've been
investing for the last six seven years
at different levels big companies small
companies the S P 500 funds you name it
but ramit changed my mind he changed my
mind on money
spending investing and he changed my
mind on something that I think
95 of you that are listening to this
podcast and they're about to listen to
this need to have your mind changed on
too that if you have the right
philosophy towards money the right
perspective and mindset towards money
then there is a path to living our rich
life
to becoming rich that enough people are
not talking about he debunks the myths
of money the limiting beliefs about
money
and he confronts all of the unhelpful
advice about money
that stands in the way of you becoming
rich
there's an app on my phone that I now
have installed because of this
conversation
and there are three big Investments that
I've now made in my life because of this
conversation
and there is one key idea
that I now believe will make me ten
times more wealthy over the next three
decades
because of this conversation
you're gonna love it
enjoy
[Music]
remains
someone's just clicked on this podcast
on YouTube on Spotify on Apple and they
saw the title they saw the thumbnail
they thought that sounds interesting
tell me why you think
they should stay and listen to what
we're going to talk about today what
they stand to gain if they give us their
time
whenever someone hears someone talking
about money
they get rigid they instantly think that
someone's going to come in and tell them
you can't spend money on lattes you
can't go on vacation you can't buy any
new clothes save all your money until
you're 90 years old and maybe just maybe
then you can spend it and I don't
believe in any of that I think you
should spend extravagantly on the things
you love as long as you cut costs
mercilessly on the things you don't
I think you should live a rich life
today
and an even richer life tomorrow and so
when you combine money and psychology
you start to understand that there is
more to a rich life than just some
number in a spreadsheet people already
know they should be saving more
they know about compound interest they
may not know the intricacies but they
understand if they invest some now
they're going to have more later
so what's stopping them that's been the
central question that I'm fascinated
with for the last 20 years that's why
when I studied human behavior and
persuasion and psychology I was obsessed
with this question of what are the
things we know we should do but we still
don't you can live a rich life
regardless of where you came from
you can live a rich life regardless of
your income
now of course having a higher income
dramatically helps
but just like Fitness we can all improve
where we are and that's what we get to
talk about today
when you talk about the language
language of money what do you mean I
mean understanding the nuts and bolts of
money so just the same way that we all
learn how to drive we learn the rules of
the road when to use our turn signals
most of us do not have even the
equivalent knowledge of money for
example the basic language of money
would be what percentage of your income
are you saving and why
what percentage are you investing and
why when will you have a hundred
thousand dollars or five hundred
thousand or a million dollars and what
will that money get you because just
having a million dollars in the bank is
pointless what does it get you
specifically
this is the basic language of money
you've got to know your key four six
numbers in your life not many just a few
but once you understand those numbers
it's like understanding the speed limit
understanding the speed limit means you
understand a lot there's a rule of the
road if you go too fast what's going to
happen why do these rules exist and
these rules are similar in money you can
break them
that's okay but you got to understand
the rules first what are those numbers
that I need to know there's four numbers
that I really like to track I track
these myself and these are the numbers I
encourage the first is your fixed costs
those would be your rent or your
mortgage your in uh your any debt
payments groceries the money that you
are spending every single month that is
essentially fixed
and the number I recommend for that is
50 to 60 of your take-home pay
so that would be if you're spending 50
to 60 percent of what you make what you
take home on your rent your groceries
any debt payments your car
you're in good shape okay the next one
is your savings that would be roughly
five to ten percent savings would be
things like an emergency fund savings
for a down payment for a car things like
that
third is Investments uh this is where
the real wealth is created and for this
five to ten percent of take home is fine
of course the more you put in the more
you're gonna have and then the fourth
category the one I love the most is
called guilt-free spending
this is going out for cocktails in New
York it's buying a beautiful shirt it's
treating your friends whatever you love
yoga
20 to 35 percent of your take-home pay
so if you're watching or you're
listening to this just take 15 minutes
back of the napkin jot down your
approximate numbers you don't even have
to get them perfect and you will be able
to Benchmark how you are spending
compared to those numbers
I'll tell you that those numbers tell me
a lot it's almost if you just show me
those four numbers of your spending I
can tell so much I can tell what you
love spending on I can tell what you
don't I can tell what your priorities
are
and I can also tell where you are out of
alignment
so I'll give you an example
when I ask people what is your rich life
one of the common answers they say is I
want to do what I want when I want I go
oh God not this answer again I hear it
every day I go wow that's so interesting
so what do you want
they go
uh uh most people have never thought
Beyond a trite answer
so then the next answer I often get is
freedom I want freedom I go great that
sounds good
what is freedom I want to do what I want
when I want I look at their numbers and
I see
a huge payment that they're making to a
30-year mortgage
I see debt payments I see car payments
and I go now this is interesting you
want freedom but you have essentially
anchored yourself down to not be able to
travel or to Pivot or to move
how can those two be how can you
reconcile those two and that dissonance
is actually a fascinating moment I love
when we experience dissonance we all do
I say that I want to work out more but I
don't work out more why
and what you'll discover is people often
they simply have never thought about it
what what our rich life is these Genera
these generic phrases Freedom
flexibility it's just words
what I really want somebody to say I
want them to go a lot deeper is to say I
want to be able to travel for six weeks
a year I want to go to London I want to
go to New Delhi I want to go to Thailand
because I want to visit my family
that's a good start if we get even more
specific they tell me what seat on the
airline they're sitting on they tell me
where they're eating they tell me who
they're bringing with them
but to Simply say I want freedom
is so vague that when I look at your
numbers there's often a huge incongruity
with how you're spending versus what you
claim your rich life is how many people
from your experience of interviewing
people and doing this research
are clear on what their rich life looks
like
down to you know what you described
there I want to travel for a couple of
months a year and then even further down
to which seat I'm going to be in which
class I'm going to be on as I travel
less than one percent less than one
percent of people know that no most
people literally say I want to do what I
want when I want that is their the
extent to which they've thought about a
rich life why does it matter to be what
did that one that less than one percent
of people that have that planned out
have as an advantage or a benefit from
that meticulous thought that the other
99 don't have because they can craft
their rich life that is uniquely theirs
almost like getting a handmade glove and
in fact the more you craft your rich
life the more bewildering it looks to
the outside world so I'll give you an
example from my own life I love to
travel
I spend a lot of money when my wife and
I we go we'll travel for months at a
time
I love hotels I love the hospitality I
love the details I I love it all
I don't really care about cars not at
this phase of my life it's just not that
important to me
so when I talk about my money dials or
the things that I love to spend money on
I might spend
a crazy amount on a hotel per night just
because I love it
but I drive a car that's almost 20 years
old it's just not important to me
and I want that I want to hear in your
life what you spend extravagantly on but
then you cut costs mercilessly on
because I want that Duality which
indicates you are intentional about your
rich life what if we're buying things to
impress other people and we don't
because it's hard to un looking in from
the outside especially it's hard to know
if someone actually likes Lamborghinis
yeah or if they're buying Lamborghinis
because they were beat up when they were
nine years old on the playground and
they're trying to overcompensate and
make the world and does it matter where
they're buying it does it matter I don't
know first of all how would we even know
how would they know is there is there a
difference do you think just on your in
your opinion on the impact that that
purchase has on us whether we're doing
it intrinsically or we're doing it
extrinsically because I reflect on
some of the things that I spent money on
and I go that was for someone else
whereas there's other things I spend
money on which are maybe health related
or travel related like convenience
flying in a nice class on a plane which
I know that's actually adding a lot of
benefits to my life whereas that Mansion
I bought out in the countryside when I
was 23 or whatever
was a terrible decision it took me away
from my friends because it was an hour
and a half outside of the city yeah and
none of my friends ever came to it so I
was just arriving at midnight after work
in this mansion with this Tennis
Court by myself sleeping for three hours
and then driving another hour and a half
back to the city where all my friends
and work were I go that was a stupid
decision based on extrinsic
external you know motivations it's a
great question and you know
particularly in America we love this
idea of ownership we are taught you've
got to own owning a house is the best
investment it means you are successful
and if you're renting
no one really says this but what they
deep down say is you're a loser yeah
okay
this individualistic strain really runs
deep and it has led a lot of people to
make poor financial decisions uh first
of all you might be surprised to hear my
view is that owning can be a good
financial decision but it also can be a
very bad financial decision in fact I
rent by choice and living in New York
for example I lived here for a long time
I knew
that if I were to buy I would be losing
thousands of dollars every single month
because it actually cost more than twice
as much to own than to rent
but can you imagine the type of
pressures even I got from people who
would come over and say oh
so do you own this place the place that
I was renting I said no I rent
and there was this visible moment of
confusion they're shaking my hand they
know that I'm the I will teach to be a
rich guy
but I rent how can you be teaching money
but you rent isn't renting for losers
and I have to say because I was Rock
Solid confident in my decision
that pressure did not affect me
but I want to also say that
a lot of us buy things based on status
like the idea that we don't buy things
based on what people around us think is
is nonsense we buy things based on
status to deny it is absurd
but I do think that for the big
purchases in your life like a house a
car the big things
you've got to run the numbers
and if you decide hey you know what I
want to buy a house even though it's
going to cost me an extra six hundred
thousand dollars in opportunity costs
and Phantom costs but I'm gonna do it
because I like it or it makes me feel
good I say God bless
if you simply make decisions based on
what other people around you do then you
will discover like you did
I thought I was going to feel a certain
way and I don't really feel that way and
that for me is an opportunity for you to
interrogate your own beliefs and money
is a
like a personal zerosome game right like
so I can't just spend indefinitely so
buying that ridiculous house out in the
countryside takes away from something
which might have
genuinely brought me closer to happiness
like I don't know going with my family
or whatever it might exactly you talk
there about buying property I find that
really curious because the the popular
narrative is for most people the minute
they get any decent amount of money is
to buy your first house and that's what
people do they get they take a 10
deposit or 20 deposit whatever it might
be and they buy a house
um why is that
a poor investment
why is that a bad thing to do because
that does kind of sit counter to the
popular narrative well we have to
remember first of all where the popular
narrative came from
in America if you ask people what is the
American dream
yeah the answer is inextricably tied up
with a single family home with a white
picket fence that's not an accident that
is the result of Decades of messaging
some might call it propaganda
first of all most people in the world do
not live in single-family homes like we
do in America that has caused a lot of
issues but to leave that part aside
this is how most people think about
buying a house they think Grandma bought
a house in Austin Texas in 1970 for a
hundred thousand dollars grandma just
sold it 50 years later for one million
dollars grandma made 900
000 they go it's the most profitable
thing you could do buy a house
I go okay that sounds really nice did
granny factor in
how much she spent on maintenance for
the past 50 years uh no uh did granny
factor in inflation and how that
affected her return uh no what's
inflation uh did granny factor in the
opportunity costs of what that down
payment could have been used if invested
in the S P 500 uh no and did granny look
at all these Phantom costs such as
interest on the loan uh no
it's not simply the bigger number minus
the smaller number that's wrong that is
simplistic
for the biggest purchase of your life
you've got to go deeper again when I was
living here I kept a very close eye on
real estate and the place right right
next to me same square footage same
number of bedrooms same everything it
would have cost 2.2 times what I was
paying in rent so just to give you an
example if I was paying three thousand
dollars a month it would have cost about
sixty four hundred dollars a month to
own
okay I said you know what I like renting
if I have a problem I just text my
landlord I took the thirty four hundred
dollars I would have spent owning when
factoring in Phantom costs maintenance
interest taxes all that and I simply
invested it and I made more money doing
that than I would have owning what about
if you're buying somewhere to for the
rental income that can work that can
work so owning real estate as an
investment can be part of a
well-diversified portfolio if you run
the numbers right now there's a lot of
hype people go I'm gonna buy a house and
if I don't like it or whatever I'm just
going to rent it out okay fine but
you've got to remember that if your
mortgage is a thousand dollars
that's not just the amount you're paying
there's a lot more in fact in my
estimations I add 50 to that price so
fifteen hundred dollars a month which
would include a roof repair happening 19
years from now we've got to amortize
that out uh labor costs interest all
that
if you can rent it out and make a profit
fantastic
it cash flows that's awesome
what you discover is that most people
who buy a primary residence the place
they want to live in they buy it because
they want it and then they tell
themselves it's an investment
buying a house can be an investment but
oftentimes it's not and they're far
better far simpler Investments here's my
key message I want to make sure nobody
misunderstands me I've been accused of
saying buying a house is bad no I never
said that in fact I will buy a house
myself one day and when I do it's going
to be a terrible financial decision and
I'm going to do it anyway
my key message is for the biggest
purchase of your life you've got to run
the numbers sometimes buying can be a
good financial decision often renting
can be a good financial decision run the
numbers and never feel guilty for
renting
as it relates to buying a house I've
always been hesitant because I'm
scared really of the point you mentioned
about being anchored to a location so I
the way that I've kind of Justified that
away is by saying well I'll just Airbnb
it when I'm not there or I'll rent it
out when I if I decide to move to New
York or whatever is there a a cost in
the opportunity of being less flexible
about where you can be
um that people don't think about
especially when they're younger yes and
they're probably a little bit
unencumbered by you know life yes at
that point yes buying a house is one of
the most profound financial decisions
that will affect your lifestyle ever
you can sell a car even at a minor loss
but selling a house involves massive
transaction costs and labor that most
people don't anticipate
one of the reasons that I rent is for
lifestyle reasons Financial yes I make
more money renting and investing the
difference than I would owning but also
lifestyle I don't know that I'm going to
be in the same place for 10 years which
is one of the key things that I would
encourage people to decide before they
buy you want to know that you're going
to be there for at least 10 years
because then you can spread all those
transaction costs
spread them out over 10 years they
become much more affordable it's kind of
like buying an expensive jacket if you
buy it and you wear it once that's
really expensive if you buy it and wear
it over 10 years it becomes a lot more
affordable now take that multiply it by
a thousand and that's a house
particularly for young people
I don't give a lot of unsolicited advice
I used to do it when I was young when I
just learned about money and I realized
nobody really wants to hear it they
really don't
if somebody comes to me they come to my
blog my social media great otherwise I'm
not going around telling people you
should do this
once in a while though I get a young
person asking me I'm just about to
graduate from college what advice do you
have for me
and at that moment the the best piece of
advice that I have is move where the
action is
and typically that's a big city so that
would be where there's more jobs where
there's simply more people if you're
looking for relationships and there's a
lot of tacit knowledge that happens in
big cities
like oh have you tried this oh what have
you seen that musical uh have you tried
this thing this idea that's going around
so often surrounding yourself
geographically can be hugely rewarding
to you as you grow you can't do that if
you bought a house because everybody
told you that it was going to be the
best investment and if I were to say
show me where you calculated the numbers
that it was going to be in a great
investment
75 plus percent of people have never
created a simple spreadsheet how does
buying a house compare in terms of
returns to something like investing in
the S P 500 it's quite poor actually
really yeah over about a hundred years
there's great research showing that it
has essentially matched inflation it's
been slightly above inflation people
find this mind-boggling again because
they think somebody bought a house for
100k and they sold it for a million so
it's 900k but they don't properly factor
in inflation opportunity costs Phantom
costs all that it's really hard to
factor these numbers in but it's
critical because it's the biggest
purchase of your life I'll give you
another example of where people don't
properly Factor it in
uh some people pay a financial advisor
one percent they go one percent it's not
a big deal I'll pay one percent
what they don't realize is that that one
percent over the course of their
lifetime will take 28 of their returns
and hand them over in fees
think about it if you make a million
dollars in investing over the course of
your life 280
000 are going right out of your pocket
into that advisor's pocket now that's
super counterintuitive one percent turns
into Twenty Eight percent how does it
work you can simply go online and search
for uh investment cost calculator and
plug in the numbers at a one percent fee
and you will see
point of this is that sometimes money is
highly counterintuitive really
counterintuitive it's unlike anything
else if you and I go to sushi right now
and we get sushi for 20 bucks it'll be
fine if we get it for a hundred bucks
what do you think probably be a little
better right and if we get it for a
thousand dollars the fish will have been
flown in from Tokyo this morning and it
will be served in an absolutely stunning
setting
so in other words you pay more you get
better results we're used to that if I
spend more on a sweater it's probably
gonna have a different type of fabric
more on a car it's going to look cooler
have cooler features
money's not like that if you spend more
you don't get better returns you don't
get better anything in fact if anything
you get worse returns
people find this mind-boggling because
it is it's counterintuitive but in
investing costs matter in buying a house
you've got to run the numbers because
they are totally counterintuitive
quick one before we get back to this
episode just give me 30 seconds of your
time
two things I wanted to say the first
thing is a huge thank you for listening
and tuning into the show week after week
means the world to all of us and this
really is a dream that we absolutely
never had and couldn't have imagined
getting to this place but secondly it's
a dream where we feel like we're only
just getting started and if you enjoy
what we do here please join the 24 of
people who watch this channel regularly
and have hit that subscribe button means
more than I can say and if you hit that
subscribe button here's a promise I'm
gonna make to you I'm gonna do
everything in my power to make this show
as good as I can now and into the future
we're going to deliver the guests that
you want me to speak to and we're going
to continue to keep doing all of the
things you love about the show
thank you thank you so much back to
episode so what is the S P 500 for
anybody that doesn't know yeah and what
are the returns that I'm likely to get
from investing in the S P 500 I really
want to simplify this for people that
are at the very start of their investing
Journey you know because I mean this is
what you spend so much of your time
doing that I just think about my my team
here instead of the Diary of a CEO
there's about 30 people and we started
talking about money one day and it was
mind-blowing how nobody in my team's
lives had ever had the conversation with
them about investing we all think of
investing as something that rich people
after the age of 40 do once you have a
million dollars
um or if you don't have a million
dollars then the only other way to
invest we're taught is to buy a house
driving me insane it's true though isn't
it yes and
and central part of my work is that you
can live a rich life and that rich life
can be richer and more vibrant and more
personal than you ever imagined if you
want to travel you can travel for longer
than you ever thought you can travel for
me at nicer hotels you can spend more
time with your children with your loved
ones whatever your rich life is you can
do that but you've got to learn a few
key basic things about investing and
money so let me tell you what I would
tell my family when they come to me and
they go how should I start investing
the simplest simplest way that I advise
my family
is I say get a Target date fund so let
me explain what that is a Target date
fund is One Fund just one
and you pick it based on the year that
you're going to retire
so if you're going to retire in 2050
if you're going to be 65 in 2050 you go
and you find that one fund it's called a
Vanguard 2065 fund or Fidelity 2065 or
Schwab 2006. there's lots of brokers
These funds it's One Fund all you do is
put money into it that's it the fun like
a pie chart is automatically Diversified
so as you get older it gets more
conservative because somebody who's 75
years old should be investing
differently than someone who's 25.
One Fund all you have to do is set your
money up to go into it every single
month what is a fund a fund is a a set
or a basket of stocks and maybe bonds so
we've all heard of you know companies
like Microsoft Google whatever
a fund owns lots of these right and
that's important because we've heard
diversification like you should have
Diversified your Investments okay well
how do I do that you don't need to go
and buy 20 stocks and then figure out
how much of each to do that's too much
work and honestly most people are not
good at that even professionals
you buy a fund which automatically owns
lots of stocks like hundreds of them
and over time all you the individual
investor like me have to focus on is
putting money into it automatically so a
fund essentially I've got 100 pounds
that I want to invest
um I find a fund where do I find these
funds you can go to Vanguard Schwab or
Fidelity all those are great companies
uh what you're looking for regardless of
what country you're in is you're looking
for a low-cost brokerage firm so but
there's also apps and stuff that I can
you can use apps I don't like a lot of
the apps because they gamify you to try
to invest right they want you clicking
and trading I hate Traders trade you do
not want to be a Trader Traders lose
money investors treat investing like
watching paint dry that's how sexy it is
trust me I'm not getting my
entertainment from investing I'm going
out go watch a movie go watch Netflix
but investing is boring and automatic
that's how it should be I used a a
company called hargreave lands down in
the UK who have an app when I first
started investing
um when I first started investing in
funds they they had a very ugly app so I
wasn't very compelled to use I think
it's better now but I would use just do
it on desktop which I do get your point
because you don't want to you don't want
to be gay you don't want to scream yeah
all of that note I like uglies it should
be ugly and you don't want it to be too
accessible correct I don't want to be
able to check it every day no look on my
phone you will see no investing apps yes
there should not be why do you need to
log in and check it every day what's the
point yeah in fact I log you know what
most people should check it every three
to six months and here's how you check
it you log in on your desktop
wow it's up wow it's down okay bye
you're not tweaking anything it's like
making Thanksgiving dinner once you've
put the turkey in the oven
just let it sit do not fiddle with it
because you're only going to mess it up
and in this case you're letting the
turkey cook for decades and that fun so
I've got 100 pounds I go on a website
Vanguard Fidelity Schwab whatever they
are I have no Alliance to any of them
neither do I um there's various ones in
the UK I actually do recommend Hargrave
Lansdowne just because it's quite simple
and I think investing in funds there's
no fees there's no fee associated with
the investment itself obviously they
take you know they might take a
percentage depending on which fund
you're investing in I take my 100 pounds
and investing in Hargreaves lands down
you don't need there's no
um minimum great from what I understand
and there's no if you invest in a stock
they charge 12 pounds per investment but
if you invest in a fund it's free
um I put my hundred pounds into a fund
the fund is essentially taking one
pounds one of those pounds and investing
one pound into Facebook it's investing
one pound into Google one pound into
Shopify one pound into Spotify one pound
into Nvidia or whatever it's doing that
for me it's managing it for me it's
making the decisions for me I just put
the money in
every month whatever I can and I leave
it yeah and let's go even deeper I love
that we're getting into the nuts and
bolts here because you know honestly
most people they do not know how to
invest literally what website do I go to
and then what do I do
the fund owns these different stocks and
some will go up and some will go down
and it's inconsequential to you all you
need to know is you own this fund
now that you've opened up an account and
you've sent a hundred bucks or a
thousand bucks great you've made one of
the most important decisions of your
life now there's just one more thing you
have to do set up an automatic transfer
so that every single month you have a
certain amount of money going in
now if you don't know how much money use
my conscious spending plan guideline
what did I say five to ten percent of
take-home is a good guideline all right
you should be able to do five percent
trust me anyone who comes to me they go
Remy there's no way must be nice I can't
afford I go show me where you're
spending your money I guarantee you I
can find five percent to send in every
month now you're not trying to send it
in I don't try to brush my teeth in the
morning it's a habit investing is even
easier than brushing your teeth because
you set it up automatically the
investment fund will automatically draw
from your checking account
and it will pull in a hundred bucks 500
bucks a thousand bucks whatever your
number is
and so you're not going to log in for
three four five months you're going to
log in a few months later you're gonna
be like oh my God
I didn't even realize
that all this money is in here
when you add that plus compounding over
many years that is how real wealth is
created so I don't want anyone to think
that you have to be rich in order to
start investing one of the ways you get
rich is by investing I've got a friend
that's currently actually in this
building at the moment and I had this
conversation with them about a year ago
gave the advice that you've just given
there and about two months later this
individual who I shot name came to me
and I said How's your you know your your
Investments going in in that fund and
they said oh yeah I had bills I had a
credit card bill so I took it out oh
yeah she treated like a checking account
Investments for me are
places to accumulate wealth I don't draw
from it that's what a checking account
is for so if what that is is there's two
parts to what your friend is saying one
is
um mentally she's thinking that this
investment account is just money I can
draw from if I need it so I would sort
of gently change the way she thinks
about it the second is I guarantee her
account structure is a little
um subpar so here's how I would set it
up this is in chapter five uh it's all
automation because trust me I don't want
to spend time transferring money back
and forth that's I don't spend any time
on that
you get paid your money goes into your
checking account from your checking
account it is automatically transferred
to a savings account in fact I have sub
savings accounts for vacation car down
payment all that stuff so you have money
set up for specific goals
money is transferred to your investment
account
it's transferred there I'm not going to
touch that money I'm going to let it
cook and then I have my guilt-free
spending which is going out with friends
whatever I love and my credit card bill
is automatically paid off every single
month
that's how you want to set it up it
takes a couple of weeks to set
everything up and then you never have to
think about it again
how can you prove to me that this is the
way to make wealth what case studies
have you got that investing in funds
over a long period of time is the path
to financial wealth because you know
it's you said earlier about the paint
drying thing the narrative that we see
about how why people and how people get
rich is you know they sell a company or
they have a lottery win or maybe they
buy some cryptocurrency and it goes up
yeah that's what we hear that's what
we're trying to emulate totally we prove
to me that that's that this fun strategy
is better well there's there's a couple
things first off the research over more
than 100 about a hundred years shows the
returns of the stock market and the
returns tend to be at least in America
they tend to be around 11 percent
10 to 11 and if you take out inflation
you get about seven to eight percent per
year now for anyone listening they go
okay well what does that mean that
number means nothing to me seven percent
whatever
if you go right now and you Google
investment calculator and you just plug
in your age you plug in let's say 200
300 bucks a month and you plug in seven
percent return and you just watch how
that money grows
you will be shocked Jack give me my
phone I'm gonna do it now
okay so let's search for compound
interest calculator and there's a really
simple one this it's called money chimp
okay
okay I've got it all right
all right so there's four numbers we
need to fill out here let's take a look
the first is current principle that
means how much you've got in the bank
I'm gonna say
five thousand dollars and I'm gonna
start when I was 16 because if I'd saved
my money when I was 16 and not spent
recklessly I think I could have had that
five thousand dollars when I was 16. um
annual Edition what does that mean how
much can you invest per year so for most
people they think about on a monthly
basis they might say 200 bucks a month
which would be twenty four hundred
dollars annual Edition
okay so what do you want to say I'm
gonna say can I say five thousand
dollars yeah that's you know about 400
bucks a month I think that's reasonable
I often find that with people making uh
median or slightly above median salary
that they're hundreds of dollars a month
of money that is unaccounted for that if
properly made intentional could be
invested so great five thousand a year
all right obviously I could have once I
got past a certain age I could have
increased that though so we're going to
talk about that okay hold on to that
idea okay how many years this was you at
20 this was me at 16. oh okay and how
old are you today 30. okay so 14 years
let's just do it until today and we'll
see what happens okay all right 14 years
and then it says interest rate so what
should we assume for that is that eight
percent yeah seven to eight I you I do
seven just to be super conservative
because I never want to be surprised on
the downside right if anything I'm going
to make more so seven percent all right
let's calculate it
okay what do you see
Tom what do you see
133 000 537. yeah that's what you would
have had right now now let's add some
context so this is really important you
see a number that says 133 000 at age
30. yeah okay
is that a lot is that not hmm I don't
know
let's break it down at that point you
started with five thousand dollars and
you invested five thousand dollars per
year
we assumed no raises even though you
obviously made more than you made at age
16. we assumed you stopped investing at
age 30 which is obviously ridiculous
and you end up with six figures let's
play it out
let's take it until 40.
so instead of 14 years
you invested for 24 years what do you
see
I would have
336 000 it's getting better
from just five thousand dollars a year
it's not much it's fantastic again 400
bucks or so a month is very modest
remember people's income goes up
typically in their 30s and 40s and if
you already are investing a little bit
automatically all you have to do is just
tweak a number and it will take an extra
couple hundred three four five hundred
bucks let's do one more let's go to 34
years just because I want to see what
happens and then we're going to play
with the other numbers
okay so
investing from the age of 16 until I'm
50 mm-hmm
I would have
736 000 in my account yeah now I want to
do the full the full thing I want to do
a more realistic number here so instead
of 50 we're gonna go
49 years
that takes you to age 65. yeah okay and
instead of five thousand dollars per
year your income obviously went up from
being 16 years old so I'm gonna pick a
number out of thin air and and I'm gonna
tell you how I picked it I'm going to
say instead of five thousand dollars a
year it's actually going to be
thirty thousand dollars per year let me
tell you why I picked that
in your early years you don't have as
much money but you were still investing
a little bit which shows that you're
dedicated as your income goes up
you're going to start proportionally
continuing to invest so at a certain
point your income will be really high
and that will bring that average up
that's why I switched it to 30 000 per
year I actually think this is quite
modest but I'm gonna go ahead and do it
so here we have someone starting
investing at five thousand dollars they
invest thirty thousand dollars per year
okay they grow it for 49 years at seven
percent
do you know the math
no tell me
12 million three hundred and three
thousand dollars
so that's me starting with 5K gradually
ratcheting it up until I'm investing
well investing 30k on year a year per
average across those 49 years yes which
is a flaw in this because it's so simple
that money invested you are not actually
going to invest that much early on
you'll invest more later yeah so you
won't actually you'll maybe have a
marginal amount less but we're talking
10 versus 12 million that's a lot of
money
and then if I got eight percent instead
of the seven percent I'd have 17.4
million yeah but don't mess with that
because this is what people do they go
well if I got 13 I'm gonna invest in
this PE fund I go don't do that you're
gonna lose all your money just stop yeah
seven percent is safe it's conservative
that's why I am here that's why I want
to encourage people you don't need to
juice your returns I hope you do get
eight percent but I don't want you to
count on that I want you to count on
safe stable returns and what matters for
you is the time you started early and
the amount you have a considerable
amount to invest
what about the richest people in the
world you know we think of the Warren
buffetts of the world or the Charlie
mongers of the world who ended up
becoming the richest investors on planet
Earth yeah what was their strategy I'll
tell you let's talk about Warren Buffett
uh there's a friend of mine Morgan
housel he wrote this amazing artist I
love that book yeah the psychology money
he wrote this amazing article about
Warren Buffett if you look at Warren
Buffett's returns
he started investing at a very young age
and the money compounded again it's like
putting the turkey in the oven and
letting it sit there not just for an
hour but many hours in his case 60 plus
years
he has made over 90 I think over 99
percent of his wealth happened over the
age of 60.
okay think about that it's all because
he started investing so far ago and what
is mind-boggling is that you don't need
a fancy strategy you don't need to be
picking individual stocks you don't even
need to be a genius
to make a lot of money you do not have
to be the smartest person in the room
you just need to remember a few key
things start as early as possible
okay and if you're not 16 years old if
you're 30 40 even 45 okay start now
second invest aggressively every single
month that's critical third keep your
costs low one percent in fees is going
to take 28 of your returns two percent
is going to take over 55 of your returns
keep your costs low
if you do those things you will have
more money than you ever imagined what
are the attributes of someone that's
probably going to be poor in 30 years in
terms of that relationship and their
behavior with their money they're easy
they don't invest they feel overwhelmed
and anxious about money and they talk
about it all the time but they've never
read a single book about money
and there's these deeper attributes they
have only rich people invest they think
that yeah and that's why I'm here I want
Everyday People to know just like me I
started off my parents immigrated from
India I had no special uh
investment knowledge but I had two
parents who were educated and encouraged
me and said learn this stuff here we'll
do it together and that was a gift
everyday people can build tremendous
wealth which in and of itself is
impressive but it's even more impressive
when that wealth is used to live a rich
life a rich life of adventure and
spontaneity and generosity some of the
stats I pulled out from your book about
25 percent of people who make a hundred
thousand dollars a year plus a still
living paycheck to paycheck
according to a recent survey of
millionaires done by the U.S trust 83
percent of the wealthy wealthy say their
largest investment gains have come from
small wins over time rather than taking
big risks yes this is counter to
everything we see on TV because on TV
it's really boring what are you going to
look at my Vanguard account oh wow
compounding seven percent per year it
went down eight percent last year and it
went up nine percent this year so boring
so we see these cool stories of business
owners and we're both business owners it
is cool but a tremendous amount of my
own wealth will come from low cost
long-term methodical investing that's
like a rule of life isn't it that the
the real returns you know in reality the
great Returns come from patience and
consistency and things that really
aren't sexy like they're not
instagramable if I post on my Instagram
today hey I've got some advice for you
guys to become wealthy and I go I need
to invest in this fun then just leave it
there but if I go listen I've got this
new NF this new nft collection or
cryptocurrency coin that's gonna make
you a million percent this year
people are going to go all in that's
just like something within the human
condition where we want we want
big returns with little effort and today
we want to get rich quick same with a
six-pack we want the six-pack abs in 10
minutes we don't want six pack abs with
diet restrictions and nine months of
work that's not and that is why I have a
lot of compassion for helping people
unlearn some of the messages about money
because we all have them uh we all have
the equivalent of I want six-pack abs
but we also have something in life that
we've spent time to get really good at
and we know that the secret is basically
consistency if I go ask someone who's an
amazing cook
hey I want to cook like you how do I do
it what are they going to give me some
use cinnamon no they're gonna say get in
the kitchen and cook every single day
for five years and you're gonna learn
about when to use salt and when to cook
it for longer Fitness you want to ask
someone who looks really good or or
feels really good about their body
they're going to give you some secret
workout no they're gonna say I show up
when I feel good I show up when I don't
I show up when you let's think about the
people that might be listening now so
there's going to be someone that is a
they're a they're a bus driver or they
are a social media manager they are a I
know cleaner they're a teacher they are
a personal trainer
if you were if your job was to make that
person a millionaire in 20 years from
now whatever your age they are right now
what is and you were there financial
advisor in fact you were controlling all
of their personal professional decisions
talk me through what you would do with
that individual at a very detailed level
I would do a few things number one that
the most important things I would do
would be set up automatic investing and
be aggressive about it two they have to
increase their income okay I'm gonna be
that person I'm gonna embody that person
like I just described so increase my
income I'm a personal trainer perfect
okay so so what should I do all right
you're a personal trainer so first off I
would say how much are you charging how
are you finding your clients we talk
about that and let's say you're charging
100 bucks an hour and you have clients
who say how long do they stay on average
uh that's exactly what I'm changing
perfect great
they stay longer than two months I'm
very good
how long do they stay three months three
months wow okay you're very good all
right so your average client is worth
400 uh
a few thousand bucks yeah great so
you're making let's say 60 70 000 a year
all right
uh the first thing after I understand
all this information I would say all
right we're going to double your income
how are we going to do that
the first answer everyone gives is I've
got to find more clients okay you should
you should ask your clients hey I've got
a few slots available who would you
recommend so you should get more clients
second you're going to listen to your
clients and you're going to say what
else are you looking for I know you've
got your fitness journey you're going on
they're going to tell you I've got a
10-year reunion I want to plan for that
uh another person is going to say gosh I
I know I should be eating healthier but
it's really hard for me so you're
thinking about it here's what you do
you create you package up meal planning
Services you can either do their macros
for them and charge them a little bit
extra let's say an extra 200 bucks a
week or 200 bucks a month you can also
partner with a food delivery service and
you coordinate with that company to feed
over their macros and it gets delivered
to them and you take a small cut right
there you've added thousands and
thousands of dollars per year
per client as long as they stick with
you in addition to that you can do group
sessions so you go hey I'm going to do a
weekend session I'd like for you to
invite your friends invite them for free
and of course of the people who come
let's say you get 15 20 people to come
you do a free little session on Saturday
you go I'm a trainer I work in SoHo I
have three open slots that's how you're
finding new clients now so you're doing
two things you're finding new clients
you're increasing your average lifetime
value per client okay that's the that's
two things now let's do one last thing
let's increase the duration that they
stick with you they're sticking with you
for three months give them a special
offer to stay with you for six months
so when they sign up they work out with
you for a month you say look it's a
hundred bucks right now if you stick
with me for a six month plan I will give
you my sessions at ninety five dollars
per plan you'll save x five percent
one two three you've increased and if we
did the math
you may have doubled your Revenue you
certainly boosted your profit in a huge
way all of a lot of that's about making
sure you're getting a better return per
hour you spend at work but also making
sure all of those hours are full then
doubling down and making sure each hour
because that's your your currency when
you're a personal trainer you're trading
in your time I need to make the most
from every hour I spend
um I've thought about something recently
as I've been writing my new book The
Diary of a CEO um which I've written
these 33 laws for building and becoming
great essentially it goes across
marketing and business whatever and one
of the chapters that I investigate is
this idea of making sure your skills are
on the right market so my company went
public and one of the things that I I
came to learn from sitting with
investment bankers for many many years
was that if you put a company the exact
same company let's just say it's you
know
the company that make these silver mugs
in front of me if I take this company
public on the London Stock Exchange I
might get for example four times Revenue
if I take the exact same company and I
list it on the New York Stock Exchange
it will be valued at eight times Revenue
yeah it's the exact same company exact
same people exact same business just
moving it to a different market and what
upon leaving the social media marketing
world when I was 27 years old one of the
first calls I got was from a biotech
company ran by a billionaire friend of
mine that was going public
and they brought me in and on the first
week when we were discussing what they
might pay me I'm thinking they can't
really pay me in cash because I've got
enough cash I don't really need that
they can maybe give me some stock
they're offer to me for my skill set
was eight million dollars roughly eight
million dollars in options that I would
earn in nine months from taking the
company from where it was building out
the marketing team handling their
storytelling and taking the company
public which we did at about 3.2 billion
valuation
their offer was eight million dollars in
options I reflect on that and go I'd
spent the previous 10 years using the
same skill set to sell consumer goods
like dresses and iPhones for apple and
Logitech and big fashion brands yeah I
took the same skill set and applied it
to a marketing industry where it was
rare biotech people know nothing about
Reddit and Twitter and Facebook and
social media so my skill set was rare
scarce in that market so it was
incredibly valuable and I think about
this a lot with with especially as this
AI thing rolls in
I think people should be looking at
their skill sets and going where is my
skill set as a writer gonna yield the
greatest returns I could be a social
media manager I could be a uh a Blog
writer or
I could add a little boat string to my
bow and become a a scientific writer or
like work a writer in biotech and you'll
get paid if you can add that little bit
of knowledge to your to your writing
skills you'll get paid I'm gonna say
five times potentially five times more
yeah and people don't think about the
fact that they're they they need to use
Place their skill sets in the most
lucrative Market where it's scarce yeah
and I it's so yeah just throwing that
out there because it's really front of
mind for me at the moment like retaining
you know like personal should be at a
gym and you'll lose 75 of your income to
the gym or you can do it virtually you
can specialize on
um just preparing people in in the
beginning of the year it's like your
best year and every January that is your
focus it can be celebrity clients it can
be uh Uptown
um mid-career Executives that's a very
lucrative you choose but you choose
carefully I agree that's a bit of an
advanced concept I think most people
they start off they go just how do I
make more money I'm a trainer I have
three hours but once you kind of Master
that and you go like for example there's
a trainer I know here who charges 175
bucks an hour that's very good
after you get that and you fill up your
entire calendar you go okay I'm making
000 a year I want to make more how do I
do it now you need to get creative you
move to different markets you add in
package things that scale when you sleep
you have video courses Etc there's so
many different ways but I think everyone
would do well to listen to what you're
saying which is think about how to move
up Market or potentially to a totally
different Market well your skill set is
really scarce yeah and that's the
problem a lot of people have there's you
know their skill set might be too
abundant in the industry like social
media managers even social media
managers is one thing but that's a
slightly different skill set because
there's there's a wealth of knowledge
there that is unique to that knowing the
algorithms knowing the platforms there's
a real creative element to it but I
think about my friend Anthony he was he
was a graphic designer the greatest
graphic designer I ever knew in
Manchester but he was designing
nightclub flyers and he's talked about
this publicly before for not every
nightclub fly he designed he got fifty
dollars the equivalent 50 to 100 right I
had a conversation with him a couple of
years ago about this and I said you're
you you're really specifically good at
like luxury design he's got that really
like beautiful Chic simple but you know
elegant design style I always go to him
whenever I only design work like that so
I said to him
move to Dubai
and and go in there and help design
um luxury Brands yeah and this guy did
it so he went from Manchester where he
was doing nightclub flies
to moving to Dubai and without revealing
his financial position what I can say is
the same hour per
piece of work is now yielding him tens
and tens more in returns you know
instead of getting 500 he's getting
fifty thousand dollars for for a project
and it's just moving his skill set the
same thing designing on the same
software to a different industry which
will appreciate and pay more for the
same skill
the lesson I take away from that Beyond
his willingness
to actually make a change which is
amazing is that most of us do not think
in terms of discontinuous jumps we think
okay I'm making I have a hundred bucks a
month
what if I had 120 bucks a month well 20
is like quite good that's amazing but
what if I had 500 bucks a month or five
thousand that's a discontinuous jump and
to get those kind of numbers something
big has to change in business
moving markets developing a new skill
partnering all those things but it's
different in investing
it's primarily time
and that's where we're not attuned to it
we go well you know I only have like a
couple hundred bucks a month to invest
that's nothing it's only going to turn
into a few thousand you know you're not
thinking about time because the human
mind is not made for compounding so plug
it into a calculator and you will be
blown away same thing buying a house
you're only thinking of how expensive
your rent is which granted rents are
very expensive but you're not actually
factoring in how much time and money it
costs to pay taxes and maintenance and
interest on your loan you've got to get
smart about running the numbers and when
you start to sit back when you learn the
basic language of money and you
understand how you feel about money
whether it be I like status or I like
luxury or I don't really care about XYZ
when you understand your own feelings
suddenly you can almost look at the
chess board
dispassionately you sit back you go okay
I see what's going on here I even see
how I am a player on The Game of Life
when it comes to money
and then you start to say the most
powerful question of all what if
what if I earned more what if I spent
less what if I decided I actually love
traveling two months a year or buying a
house because I can decorate it the way
I want what if what if what if and then
you can start to make moves that line up
with your rich life someone comes to you
and they say what about crypto I get
that question a lot oh God what about
crypto should I be investing in that my
friends told me about this new coin and
I'm thinking of putting a couple of
thousand Pounds into it I get this all
the time should I invest in that coin
that my friend told me about
so I get this question a lot I I got it
a lot a few years ago yeah let me tell
you what happened you know people read
the book they know that I'm a fan of
low-cost long-term investing and then
all these crypto nuts grow up and well
they grow up to be you know 19 years old
and they go oh ramit seiti such an old
guy such a Luddite he doesn't understand
investing this is the new future Fiat is
dead I go
um I have a couple of questions for you
number one what is the rest of your
portfolio look like
crypto I go oh God okay
second
do you think that it's normal to get uh
four thousand percent return per year
when over about a hundred years the
stock market has returned approximately
seven percent per year they go yeah
that's because Fiat is dead you idiot
it's gonna be we're going to the Moon I
go you're going bankrupt and many of
them did lose a tremendous amount of
money my view on crypto is if you have a
well-diversified portfolio well
Diversified and you want to have a
little bit of fun with one two even five
percent of your portfolio go ahead
and that could be crypto it could be an
individual stock it could be investing
in your friend's bar in Brooklyn could
be whatever you want
but you got to limit your risk and what
you find is that the type of people who
tended to be attracted to crypto tended
to be extremely risk seeking and in fact
they saw diversification and risk
management as boring for old people
this game is a marathon you want to live
a rich life you want to be living it for
60 70 years I'm not trying to get
ten thousand percent returns and then
blow out
and that's what happened to many of them
I mean part of the problem here is that
when we do get our 10 000 returns ten
thousand percent return moment yeah we
think it's going to be 10 million
percent if we just but we also go tell
everybody oh of course you never hear
anyone saying let me tell you something
thank you for saying that I went on
Twitter because uh you know I mess
around with these crypto guys a lot on
Twitter I have a great time doing it I
go hey where'd all the crypto Bros go
everyone seems to have disappeared in
2023 where'd you guys go and there's
just like crickets we're in 2020 they
were really coming out you know guns
blazing I said if you have lost a lot of
money from crypto send me an email I
want to share your story I'll keep you
anonymous
I have a lot of people who follow me on
social media
I got less than three responses
we love to share our successes we love
it we do it with crypto we do it with
buying a house and selling it for a
profit we do it with business we do with
all that stuff
but you almost never hear anyone saying
oh my gosh I bought this uh I sold it
for um one-fifth the price oh and by the
way because of the transaction fees
Associated I actually lost like 80 of my
money you know or 85 of my money you
never hear that
it's deeply shameful for people to admit
that they lost money it's the opposite
of status isn't it yeah and we're not
wired to seek the opposite of status
exactly why to voluntarily bring
ourselves down in the tribe exactly we
are safety seeking we are status seeking
and so this is what happens with money
that's why I talk about prenups and why
I talk about investing and mistakes and
all of the above is that I want to shine
a light and show people if you are only
seeing the top of the iceberg all the
successes of course you feel like you're
behind of course you feel like everyone
knows something you don't but it's
complex some people make good decisions
some make poor decisions we got to look
at them all and then we will understand
what's right for us
so on my my position on crypto is um I
believe in the underlying technology of
the blockchain and I I'm I've been a big
ethereum holder for a very very long
time but it does represent less than
five percent of my portfolio although I
am a very big holder
um in ethereum and I've held it for so
long that although I'm at a I'm at a
point of profit right now I'm well aware
that I could go
um into a huge you know into the red
yeah irrespective of that it a has is
inconsequential to any decisions almost
like like my financial Financial
portfolio at large and B because of that
I have such a long-term time Horizon
that I could hold it for 30 40 years and
I've never flinched I don't check the
price sometimes I just check my password
works but I but but I'm not in I've
never traded I have no interest in that
ramits 10 Money Rules
I just want to go through these 10 money
rules because you mentioned prenups
there and I was quite curious that
number 10 in these rules is marrying the
right person but let's start at number
one
always have one year of emergency funds
yeah so for me one year of emergency
fund is conservative it's more
conservative than most lets me sleep at
night and I just keep the cash in a
savings account
it's not under my pillow cash does not
mean it's sitting under my bed please
don't try to rob me it's cash in a
savings account totally liquid and
that's what it's for emergencies
rule number two save ten percent invest
twenty percent of gross annual income
yeah this is all about the numbers that
I shared and being more aggressive with
them I know that paying myself first now
turns into way more later so I invest
aggressively rule three pay cash for
large expenses like engagement rings or
big holidays or weddings yeah this one
is controversial because for the things
that are important to me I don't want
price to be the number one concern so
I'd rather save up for it when I was in
my 20s before I ever met my wife I knew
one day I would get married and because
I'm Indian I knew we would have a big
wedding and I wanted it to be amazing so
I started putting money aside every
single month automatically I do the same
thing for trips house
Etc rule four never question spending
money on books appetizers health or
donating to a friend's charity
fundraiser yeah so the books and the
appetizers are a little weird I have
something called ramit's book buying
rule which means if you ever see a book
book that you're even remotely
interested in just buy it don't ask a
question don't equivocate just get it
because if you can learn one thing from
that book it can transform your life
appetizers when I was a kid we couldn't
afford to eat appetizers so we would eat
out every six to eight weeks if we had a
coupon we'd usually go to a pizza place
getting appetizers was inconceivable so
now when I eat out to be able to see one
or even two appetizers that look good I
go yeah I'll take them both it feels
incredibly rich and this is just an
example of how our childhood sticks with
us it feels awesome to be able to do
that rule number five business class
flights on flights over four hours long
Yes again my money rules not for anyone
else
when I used to when I was in my early
20s I would get on a flight and I would
actually in my head scoff as I was
walking from the front of the plane to
the back I feel like why would anyone
spend four times the money paying for a
first class ticket makes no sense we're
all getting to the same place ha ha ha
I wish instead of disparaging that I
would have gotten curious and I wish I
would have said
wow if somebody can afford to get those
seats why would they I wonder what
they're spending money on aren't we all
getting to the same place and if I had
gone from disparagement to curiosity
from D to C
I would have understood that some people
have their office paying for it some
people do it for health because they
want to get there they want their back
to feel good they maybe need to go to a
meeting and some people just have enough
money that they can do what they want
and when I started to become more
curious about money that opened up my
eyes to be able to spend on certain
things and spend extravagantly but also
to realize wow maybe I try this certain
type of food once cool I don't need to
do it again so for me my money rule so
that I don't have to decide every time I
take a flight boom this is my guideline
it's done it's written never have to
think about it again
rule six buy the best and keep it as
long as possible yes I love this I think
we all intuitively have this idea of
quality over quantity but if you look in
somebody's closet or you look at the
things in their house there may be some
incongruity so um for example my car is
17 years old it's a good car so I mean
for me it was a fine car I don't care it
rides fine it's a four-door Honda Accord
I told you very sensible long-term great
uh
buy the best keep it for a long time
it's the same with clothes
um those things matter to me I like that
and so I'll buy something that might
seem very expensive but I'll keep it for
a long time good for the environment as
well yeah
rule seven no limit on spending on
health or education yeah this this one
is important
um I learned when I was in my 20s and I
started training and learning from
personal trainers and nutritionists that
I really loved it and I also realized
that I needed help I needed great
teachers and So eventually I just
realized I'm gonna give myself unlimited
spending on this same for education so
I'm a teacher I teach different programs
of course I'm a student as well I want
to learn from great teachers from taking
accounting classes here at Columbia to
buying every conceivable book and
digital program there is
I've given myself the freedom to do that
and all that came from I had a
scholarship I had many scholarships that
paid my way through college and one of
the scholarships set up an account for
me at the Stanford bookstore
so when I walked in there I could get
literally any book I wanted it was like
uh Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
for a guy like me to have unlimited
books
it was like unbelievable and when I
graduated from college I realized that
would be going away
and then I remember having this
conversation with myself and saying
how much would it really cost to
recapture that feeling that feeling of
being able to get anything I wanted see
a book on the bookshelf I'll get it and
the answer is really not that much so
over time that then expanded to health
and Education Health I find really
compelling because
it's clearly clearly the most important
foundation of all of this it's clearly
the most lucrative investment any of us
could make
um because everything we've described
the rich life doesn't exist without that
Foundation yeah so it's all good
investing in your Vanguard but it
doesn't matter at all if you're gonna
die yeah if you ask people what's
important to you they'll often give you
the same answers they'll say
relationships Health maybe travel career
maybe yeah I go okay let's take a look
at your spending show me where you spend
on those things
it gets really quiet really fast now
it's one thing to spend time on
relationships and we should but we can
also spend money to enrich those things
it might be surprising your niece at a
showing of Michael Jackson or it might
be surprising your family by going home
and visiting them there are lots of ways
you can use money to enrich those
experiences same for health
it could be what you buy at the grocery
store it could be training or a gym
membership it could be whatever it is
that's meaningful for you but if we
claim something's important to us
it sure better show up in our time and
our spending rule number eight earn
enough to work only with people you
respect and like I love this one
I decided long ago that I only want to
work with people that I like and respect
and so I earn enough money so that I can
do that and to me who you surround
yourself with matters profoundly ideas
seep into your Consciousness values seep
in if I'm around people who when I look
at the calendar when I have a meeting
with them I dread it I already know it's
the beginning of the end most of us have
to work with they're right like
we yeah I say have to I shouldn't use
that word I don't like saying have to
but most of us spend most of our lives
especially the early part of our Lives
working with
um we work with people that we may not
particularly choose ourselves I think
that's probably
[Laughter]
so yes I built a life where I could make
that decision for myself I'm the CEO of
my business
but
I think what is important there is the
intentionality behind it it's like even
if I worked at a company I would be
deciding on which Division I want to
work in which boss I want to transfer
under based on do I like and do I
respect him
that's it the intention is there you
again these are my rules not anybody
else's but if this one strikes you then
the way that I would interpret this is
wow who in my life do I not like who do
I not respect do I need to be around
them maybe it's not work maybe it's the
friend that I hang out with socially on
Saturdays again we have a choice not on
everything but in the things we do have
a choice what a shame if we don't use it
rule number nine prioritize time outside
the spreadsheets yeah too many Nerds
love a spreadsheet and they they go I
gotta optimize cell b43 b43 never talk
back to me I go uh all right look yes
you need to know your numbers yes you
should be automatically saving and
investing all that yes do the conscious
spending plan but at a certain point you
won
the turkey is cooking you won you know
your numbers Turn the Page get out of
the spreadsheet a rich life is lived
outside of the spreadsheet so on a
personal level that means I spend less
than one hour per month on my finances
it all runs it's a machine it's a system
I speak to my wife we talk once every
couple of weeks about money
besides that do not spend time tweaking
because the rich life is lived having
conversations like this seeing friends
seeing my family
that's where I want to live not tweaking
things endlessly for no marginal gain
number 10.
you mentioned your wife there marry the
right person yeah maybe the most
important one of all marriage is the
most consequential
financial and relational decision we
ever make and people they're a little
weirded out by this rule they go what
does this have to do with money I go
what do you mean the partner you choose
will affect where you live what you
spend on a day-to-day basis what type of
house you buy if you do how often you
travel the values if you have children
that you pass down to kids
of course it's important
and so these are conversations that if
you are starting to date it's great time
there's natural moments in the dating
process or even the relationship process
where you can bring up money so it's
like the first time you take a vacation
together take a trip you go hey
um just wanna you know this is on my
mind I'd love to just like put it out on
the table love that you invited me on
this trip I'm so excited to go I'm just
curious how were you thinking about
paying for the trip who who in your mind
pays for it how would you see us
splitting this
that's a great way to bring it up and
you learn a lot about your partner there
are questions you can naturally ask you
know how were you raised with money what
do you remember your parents telling you
here's what I remember about my parents
genuine curiosity it also tells you a
lot about your partner
and then there's a few other natural
moments in a relationship where it just
makes perfect sense to talk about money
uh when you get engaged when you get
married you uh if and when you move in
together pre or post-marriage uh if and
when you have children there are these
natural moments where you get the gift
of being able to talk about money do
people talk about money
couples they talk about it uh when
something goes wrong
outside of that what sort of percentage
of people couples do you think talk
about money rarely it's very low I know
I speak to them all the time I ask them
when do you talk about money they go
when we're fighting or when they talk
about it it's like
it's these grooves that have been
created for 40 years oh every time she
goes to Target she spends too much ha ha
and I'm like that's not that funny like
the running joke between you is that she
spends too much at Target sounds like
resentment yeah why not it be
something different so that when you
talk about money once a month
proactively you always start off
complimenting your partner you go you
know what
I really appreciate that when we travel
you always pick the best flights
I I have total trust because you always
get us there on time and you pick the
flies that are so comfortable and I just
love you for that
that's a great way to reframe how we
talk about money but instead we often
simply do not talk about it proactively
we only talk about it when something is
a problem do you think how Partners
should know how much money we have
when you're married
probably a little before that as well
like I'll tell you what happened with my
wife and me
so in my book in chapter nine I talk
about how to talk about money and when
to talk about money
and first of all there's a lot of
personal finance experts they're like
you should talk about money on date one
I'm like have you guys ever been on a
first date can you imagine who's talking
about their asset allocation on the
first date I'm like get a life so she
had um asked me like years into our
relationship some 401K question and I
was like read this book learn it it's in
there so I knew all about her money we
had talked about her finances and then
as we started getting more serious one
day she came to me and she said
I don't feel comfortable because you
know everything about my finances and I
don't know anything about yours
and that was it
a sobering moment because I realized I
had violated my own rules in chapter 9
of talking about money early and
proactively why didn't you feel
comfortable
she didn't feel comfortable because she
felt like I knew everything and she
didn't know anything about me being in
the dark about your partner and their
finances is very uncomfortable
we were planning to get married so what
does that mean does he have debt does he
not does he have this much money or not
does he expect me to pay the exact same
amount for this apartment because I
don't know if I can afford that there
are what does it mean for children what
does it mean for our elderly parents all
that stuff
this is what money means money is not
just a amount in a spreadsheet it's
where do we live security security who
do we get to be
and you know security is a really good
that word haunts me because uh we we I
realized to my horror that I had not
shared about my finances so we had a
series of conversations
and as we got engaged
um we had more we started talking about
money a lot and I mentioned to my now
wife I said it's really important for me
that by virtue of me running a business
for so long I've accumulated this
business these assets and I love you but
it's important for me that we talk about
a prenup
and I was very very scared I had talked
to a lot of friends and I'm sharing this
because prenups are another thing that
always happen in the dark
and I don't want that I want people to
shine a light and to understand how
these conversations happen because
nobody talks about this I'm going to
talk about it
so I was nervous and all the advice
online is awful it's like um have the
conversation I'm like what conversation
what do I say or some people they tell
you to blame your lawyer my lawyer
insisted I have a prenup I'm like if I
can't be honest to my soon-to-be wife
what kind of relationship do we have so
that's what I said to her and she
responded like awesome she was like wow
I didn't expect that I don't know much
about prenups but I'd be willing to
learn more I said fantastic so we start
talking more about it we both get
lawyers as you're both required to
it was going pretty well
until
it didn't and we started really
disagreeing about money
and we were we're just like fighting and
she finally said we should go see
somebody because this conversation is
not going the right direction
and and I totally agreed with her so we
literally went on Yelp and we searched
like therapists near us and we found one
right there we went
and we sit down and this therapist was
great she asked us what does money mean
to you and she asked me first
it's so obvious money means growth like
I could literally see the compound
interest charts in front of my eyes I
know about the rule of 72 and expense
ratios
growth of course
she has the same question to my wife
my wife says
safety
like
what that's like somebody's saying
metal money means metal to me I go huh
and it was that that we realized
we saw money completely differently
completely it explained to me why my
wife wanted more money in just sitting
in a checking account
when I go but that checking account is
losing potential interest why would we
lower our yield blah blah blah we were
looking at it through two totally
different lenses
so that single question was very helpful
in us reframing our conversations it
didn't change everything overnight we
still had a lot of conversations we had
to have and even once we got married we
still have conversations now they're
different they're about spending and
investing and prioritizing but it was a
new way for us to look at the way we
related to money where did her lens come
from
childhood like most of ours same for me
in fact every time I talk to couples who
are now in the seat that I was in
I asked them what do you remember about
growing up with money and they always
tell me similar things uh my parents
never talked about money that's very
common or they said certain phrases like
we can't afford it money doesn't grow on
trees we don't talk about money in this
family Etc
imagine you hear we can't afford it a
hundred times a thousand ten thousand
times
growing up
and you turn 25 35 you start to make
decent money
but every time you go to buy something
you feel guilty and you feel anxious and
you feel like I should be saving this
money and you can't figure out why
because on paper you make more money
if you came to me on my podcast we would
trace it back and you might realize it
is something as simple and Vivid as
sitting around the dinner table and
hearing mom or dad saying we can't
afford it our childhood sticks with us
and we could change but it's so
important for us to acknowledge that it
sticks with us
if I approach my partner and I say I
want to get a prenup and they say what
you don't trust me yeah and they say no
uh what do you do is that the question
well I would say first of all I wouldn't
start off like that I think there's
that is one of the most important
conversations you're ever going to have
in your life and the subsequent
conversations so take it seriously you
show up and you explain it I explain it
perfectly and they'll turn around and
say that and they say no
they say you don't trust me uh no okay
that's a contingency you might have to
plan for so you might say okay can you
tell me why
tell me what's going through your head I
want to understand your perspective
this is a conversation it's not a
dictate trust you don't trust me yeah
would you marry that person
I would have a lot more conversations I
can't say yes or no because you can't
judge someone based on their reaction in
a situation they've never been in how am
I going to react if I got in a car
accident and I start crying can you
judge me my entire life based on that no
but let's say that we extend it and and
you and I are in a relationship and I
ask you I it's important for me by
virtue of this and that
and you go I don't you don't trust me if
you are unwilling
to even discuss it
if you're unwilling to talk to friends
to talk to lawyers to talk to people you
can find on your own or I can introduce
you to
then I think we have a bigger
disagreement about values and you know
the way that most of us think about a
prenup is it's usually some rich
telling someone who has way less money
like sign this paper or it's over and
again that's Hollywood
prenup which I learned
is all about if the marriage ends
what you had before or any agreed upon
assets stay with that person so if you
have a business and your partner and you
get married there's no prenup and
for whatever reason God forbid you
separate suddenly that business might be
at risk the portfolio that you
accumulated before you ever met your
partner
might go to them and that when you
explain it that way most people go oh
that doesn't really seem fair but the
money that you accumulate together
as Mary Partners yeah there definitely
should be an agreed upon that money
needs to be split Etc and no person
especially the partner who earns less
should be left out in the cold ever do
you notice any differences when you
speak to these couples or on your
podcast
um in
gender differences as it relates to the
people's relationship with money because
I read a lot of stuff about men being
more prone to gambling addiction and
gambling generally yeah yeah I think
there are a lot of differences I think
gender is one of the axes that people
differentiate on
um I see typically more aggressive
investing from men I typically if I see
a gender difference in investing
differences it would be much more
conservative with women I might see
words like Safety and Security used more
commonly by women
um but I think there are also other axes
uh socioeconomic class is a huge one
that we talk about and that's something
that's very uh under the covers
particularly in America but we talk
about it Point Blank if somebody tells
me I've been poor before and I can be
poor again
doesn't bother me I can tell you how
they were raised I can tell you probably
to some geographic area in fact
um if they tell me
um my parents said be seen and not heard
that tells me a lot about someone in
their financial behavior so there are
different axes that you see different
behaviors on this is
the best product that he'll have
released in recent times many of you
will think of alternatives to this but I
I've tried those Alternatives and none
of them are as tasty as fuel's Daily
Greens it was out of stock because of
the demand it's now back in stock for
everybody in the USA right now it's not
available in the UK but when you get a
chance just try it that's all I'm gonna
say
just try it and I think once you try it
you'll understand why this is such an
essential part of my life right now and
will probably become an essential part
of yours I'm someone that understands
probably from doing this podcast the
importance of having Greens in my diet
but do I achieve that every week in the
chaos of my life do I achieve that
sometimes the answer is no with heels
Daily Greens the probability of me
achieving that is now almost 100 because
of its convenience and because of the
ease of preparing this one scoop
10 second Shake
and you're ready to go over the last few
years I've realized that my first
Foundation is my health something you've
heard me talk about a lot nothing
matters more than that first foundation
so that is why I'm so excited to be
involved with a company like whoop who
are leading the charge when it comes to
bettering your health all my friends
have received free whoops from me
because once you've tried whoop I think
it's like lights turning on to your
health that's the only way I can
describe it my sleep my performance my
recovery my stress it's like someone
turned the lights on I'm sure you guys
know but for those that don't know what
whoop is it's a wearable health and
fitness coach that provides you with the
feedback and actionable insights into
your sleep recovery training stress and
overall health and I've become entirely
utterly obsessed with it if you know me
well enough you know how obsessed I am
with the smallest details I think the
Small Things compounded together produce
the biggest gains in our life and that
is exactly what woop does in my health
and fitness every single day being able
to see my one percent gains on woop has
had a profound impact on my health
journey I highly recommend you try it
all you have to do is search
join.woop.com CEO to get a free months
whoop membership on me and if you do
send me a DM and let me know how you get
on I'd love I'd love I'd love to know
when you look at really successful rich
people that are living their rich life
that might be billionaires millionaires
or just living their rich life what are
the unobvious things the the character
traits the the philosophies towards life
that you see whether it's I don't know
confidence or whatever that means
whether it's patience what are those
like character traits they're really
good at multiple things like really good
when I was at Stanford my first year
there was a Nobel Laureate professor and
the professor next to him was making a
joke but it wasn't really a joke and he
said you know you'll hear stories about
a person being an amazing chemistry
professor but they're just a disaster at
home
Etc but not him
he's a Nobel Laureate I think it was in
chemistry he's at the top of his field
in chemistry and by the way he's
published papers in music and he's an
accomplished father
that was the first time that I had been
exposed to the idea that you can be
absolutely amazing in multiple domains
because it's a comforting story we tell
us that oh this person's really good at
this but they're probably a disaster in
everything else
and what I find is that the people who
are really good at something
they're actually good at a lot of things
they take those skills and they transfer
them they show up on time
they prepare even though they didn't
need to look at all the preparation
you've done that's cool you didn't need
to but you did it and they're probably
good socially skilled there's a lot of
things they're really good at so for me
that is inspirational because it means
that I have a lot I can work on flip
that coin then on the other side people
that you would bet on give me three
character traits of people that you
would bet on never living their rich
life in terms of character traits
uh
number one they they're surrounded by
people who uh keep them down versus
build them up so that would be phrases
like um why do you need to do that
um that's weird don't get too big for
your britches okay number two
um
impulsive
they make decisions based on what's in
front of them versus
stepping back and looking at the entire
chessboard and having a long-term
perspective and if I were to ask them
tell me two things in your life that you
do with a long-term perspective they
would probably struggle to answer it
whereas a long-term thinker would be
like oh my God I could talk about this
for four hours investing parenting
travel uh what I wear on my feet and on
and on health perfect
um
and three
no personal vision of a rich life so if
I ask them what is your rich life they
go I want to do what I want when I want
I go yeah yeah what uh I want you know I
want the house and I want the car and I
go okay what type of car like a Ferrari
okay like how come a Ferrari oh it's
just cool like a red Ferrari like no
personal connection to it if they were
to say I want a Ferrari because uh you
know my uncle once had a Ferrari and I
saw the race in Italy and blah blah blah
I go wow but if it's just things objects
driving without us not enough
super interesting I wish I'd had this
conversation when I was 18.
I'd certainly be in a much different
position now I think about if I if I've
been even more Savvy with my money and I
had it compounding sooner in my life my
life would be
would be a lot different I actually I
Ponder and that's why there was such a
pause there whether it be happier
because like I don't even I don't even
know well your story brought you here
yeah what you did and look I wish I had
started squatting when I was 14 years
old I didn't know what a squat was yeah
and so
we all deal we play the cards we're
dealt with and then we make the best
with what we've got and I never want
anyone to feel like it's too late
there's always something you can do
honestly your life has turned out
obviously very fantastic but I love that
you grapple with these questions just
like anybody we all wonder is it too
late what if I'd started five years ago
and of course we can't do anything about
that
we have a closing tradition on this
podcast where the last guest leaves a
question for the next guest and the
question that's been left for you
without knowing who they're leaving it
for is
oh okay what is other people's biggest
misconception of you
I think the
biggest misconception is that I have a
very specific way of telling you what
your rich life is
but that's not true that comes across
because people often interpret what I
say about buying a house that I'm
telling you don't buy a house not true
I'm gonna buy a house one day myself
what I what I crave is encouraging
someone
to build their rich life with
intentionality don't do it like me my
rich life is mine your rich life is
never going to look like mine
nor should it the misconceptions that
I'm telling you follow this exact
formula and you will be rich no follow
this formula and you will have a lot of
money but building a rich life takes
your unique creativity and only you can
do that
do you see that as a piece of work that
we all need to do like the kind of the
exercise that you ran me through there
do you think that everybody needs to
um
do that initial piece of work yeah of
course otherwise what are we working for
you're saving money blindly that's what
the whole Journal is about you've got to
know down to the intimate detail what is
my perfect Saturday what do I not want
to do I guarantee you when I ask people
what their perfect week looks like zero
percent say I want to spend three hours
doing laundry I go great can we use
money to solve that problem easy Luggage
in the airport can we use money to solve
that problem done we never have to think
about it again
so we've got to design our rich life it
doesn't just happen to us nobody trips
and falls and lives a rich life it is
intentional and it is ongoing work and
in my opinion is one of the most
important pieces of work that we can
ever do and that's you're right exactly
what this journal does I will teach you
to be rich Journal
and throughout this journal you kind of
hold people's hand through those
exercises but for a solo or you do it
with a partner and you get to dream
about money most of us feel so nervous
and rigid and scarce about money we feel
ashamed this has almost no numbers it's
all about what does your rich life look
like and if anything you finish this and
you're dreaming bigger not smaller when
I look at this journal as I go through
it there's there's a real emphasis here
on just heightening people's turning the
lights on in terms of what money is but
really heightening their their
self-awareness about their relationship
with money as well
um which seems to be the foundation of
getting good at money and your other
book I will teach you to be rich which
is the second edition of this book the
first one came out I believe in 2009
just after the financial crash which is
perfect timing
um this one came out in 2019 so this is
an updated version of the book
I mean millions and millions of people
have bought this book they're nuts and
bolts of money if you don't know how to
get started investing if you have debt
and you're not sure what to do if you
even have questions about uh should I
buy whole life insurance the answer is
no uh should I um buy or lease a car
it's all in there no Gill no excuses no
BS just a six-week program that works
you're referred to as the new Finance
Guru and I think you know we do need new
Finance gurus because there's not enough
financial literacy from the very start
of Our Lives as you saw from my story
where I just just my relationship with
money was catastrophic and I could be in
a much I'm very aware
that I could be in a much different
position because of those early mistakes
I made and mishaps and my early
relationship with money so people do
need to start getting educated with
their money because as I said at the
start of this conversation it is about
living your rich life and that is a
subjective thing for me it was having
the freedom of choice broadly across
every facet of my life about where I
spend my time and who I spend it with
um but it is the foundation of that
freedom of choice and that's what your
book and your work does so brilliantly
and articulately it gives us the the
path to freedom of choice and we get to
choose what our rich life looks like so
thank you so much for your time thank
you for being an inspiration and being a
loud voice in the conversation around
money I know so many of the people
listening to this podcast are completely
in the dark about money and so having
these kind of conversations and having
the Practical roadmap to how we can
improve our relationship so we can
unlock the future we want is um
incredibly important now and I'm sure it
will remain incredibly important in the
future because
there's going to be a lot of influences
like Instagram and Tick Tock that are
trying to
tell us a story about money and
aspirations and what we should be aiming
at that are unhelpful and
counter-protuitive to our happiness so
thank you ramit thanks for having me
[Music]
thank you